I'm guessing that's Decimus he looks
bigger than the last time I saw him
hawker stalls another short ones use it
as toys everyone were here talking about
halo wars 2 which doesn't come out until
februari 21st but I know you Nick got a
chance to go check it out what up at 343
pretty recently right I did got to visit
343 and get my hands on Halo Wars 2 we
got to see two new modes we get to see
blitz firefight which is kind of like a
forward mode and then blitz multiplayer
which is pvp okay cool let's is new to
the series right I don't think that was
in I don't remember that being part of
Halo Wars one blitz is a completely new
kind of style for halo wars 2 they claim
that it's an easy way for people who
haven't played RTS Azure aren't familiar
with it it's a good way for that to jump
in and so blitz is a card based strategy
game each player has a 12 card deck and
in that 12 card deck you can play four
cards at a time and so you can build
custom decks depending on what cards you
have I only got to see two of the
leaders there are six liters total we
get to play with a tree ox who is the
leader of the banished which is
essentially the the bad guys in Halo
Wars 2 they're very you know ragtag
group of brutes and then the second was
Captain cutter who's the leader of the
UNSC if you played one you know who cut
her in so they each have unique cards
depending on what faction is and those
cards can be played at any time
depending on how much energy you have so
you kind of travel around the map
fighting over three capture points and
you collect energy throughout that map
as well and you play your cards
depending on how much energy you have so
how did you feel about this when you
were playing I mean like it sounds very
very different so overall like what are
your thoughts coming away after having
actually played it I know that they're
obviously going to have the classic
multiplayer mode which is like death
match where you build your base up and
you create resources and you research
certain types of units which is kind of
the way that most RTS work and so you
kind of pick and choose the way you want
to build your army right but in that
sense it is the same kind of thing where
you can build your custom deck in the
way you want to play so if you
really high-powered units you might not
have you know a lot of Marines but you
might have a condor strike which is like
the equivalent of a scarab for the UNSC
so you can play it that way but it is
weird as the cards kind of come out
randomly and so you don't know what card
you can you can skip a card for five
energy but you still don't know what
cards going to come up so you can't plan
ahead in this strategy mode as much as
you can in a regular deathmatch mode we
mentioned at the top that you would also
put a little bit of the campaign can you
tell us about what you saw of the
campaign and how it ties into the
original game so first and foremost for
those of you who played halo wars one it
was confirmed by managing editor Kevin
grace at 343 that halo wars 2 picks up
where the legendary ending left off on
Halo Wars one so the specific mission
that we got to play was pretty
straightforward kind of felt like the
original Halo Wars one where you have a
group of troops and a Spartan Jerome who
is also returned from Halo Wars one and
you're pushing your way through the map
kind of fighting different banished
forces they come at you but what was
very different in Halo Wars 2 vs. 1 was
it at the end of the mission we get to
meet a very specific character who is an
8 reacts leader his name is Decimus and
he has kind of a boss battle where you
send all your troops after him trying to
fight him and he uses all these new kind
of unique banished weapons reminds me
the cleansing beam from the original
these beams that come down and kind of
strike your entire force and so you
fight him and when you defeat him you
know he goes away and obviously there's
so much more to that than I'm sure that
went on but we didn't get to see the
cinematics and whatnot so that's cool
that there's a lot of lore to dig into
though there's a lot going on at the
really leveraging the Halo franchise yes
but it's still it felt like the classic
halo wars one style of campaign with a
little bit of a twist with that kind of
boss at the end it's nicely mixing it up
and as you mentioned at the beginning
it's been eight years since you know
original or by the time this game comes
out it will have been eight years so
it's nice that they've mixed it up a
little bit and grown the franchise in
that
absolutely so I'm sure given that we
have another four months so the game is
out we're gonna have plenty more on this
before launch so stay tuned gamespot com
for more in halo halo wars and you know
video games humans stop that much
justice will have our heads look what we
have here the baddest been collecting
supplies collect what you can we're
going to need all the help we do get
you